certains ont cédé à la tentation de la
polémique la tentation de la démagogie
au moment où l'esprit le corps de ce
prêtre n'était pas encore en paix le
contact que j'ai eu pendant plus d'une
heure avec l'église de france avec les
prêtres qui n'ont bien connu et qui ont
accueilli cette personne ici n'était pas
de ce même esprit cependant à la vérité
et à dire aux français évidemment cette
personne ait été l'objet de trois
arrêtés de reconduite à la frontière
depuis son arrivée sur le territoire
national il l'est également en 2012 le
ministère de l'intérieur et l'ofpra ont
refusé sa demande d'asile
le centre national qui en charge du
recours des juges indépendants ont
confirmé la décision de l'état puis deux
décisions administratives ont été pris
par les préfets pour le reconduire les
frontières
ces deux décisions ont été cassées par
le tribunal une strate yves donnant une
troisième décision était prise en 2019
et nous attendions le retour du tribunal
istrati de nantes
mais entre temps vous avez eu raison de
dire que suite à l' incendie qu'il ya eu
à la cathédrale de nantes ne pouvions
pas exécuter la décision d'expulsion du
territoire national de cette personne
puisqu'elle a été pendant plusieurs mois
en prison puis libéré sous contrôle
judiciaire
et ce contrôle judiciaire prévoyait
explicitement que nous ne pouvions pas
il ne pouvait pas quitter le territoire
national
en attendant la décision de justice je
rappellerai à chacune et à chacun que
cela est le cas depuis au moins 30 ans
puisque des décisions constante de tout
et jurisprudence administrative et des
décisions qui viennent là principe
fondamental du droit fait que
l'administratif vient après le
judiciaire